you'll notice that I'm always coming
from the wing over here on stage left
it's because the vast right-wing
conspiracy
thank you I needed that continuing our
study of English history we moved from
William Shakespeare to Austin Powers
both men of mystery
both poets in their own time both
strangers to flossing
Thank You boys
you know when august's laughing I feel
good
to present the award for makeup we have
the embodiment of that legendary
superspy ladies and gentlemen mr. Mike
Meyers
was it the great 19th century writer
George Bernard Shaw
or was it Joshua Gabor who said
when a woman is young she should wear a
lot of mascara and when she is older she
should wear even more I think it was
Yasha which one was Hungarian ja ja yes
anyways I am proud and honored to
present the award for best achievement
in makeup the 3 nominated films are for
Elisabeth historical portraits of the
16th century were masterfully reawakened
as nominee Jennie shirk or reached back
in time to replicate the look of the
Virgin Queen
for saving private ryan' nominees Lois
Burwell Connor O'Sullivan and Daniel C
Street Peck were enlisted to recreate
accurately the enormity of the horrors
of war for Shakespeare and love nominees
Lisa Westcott and Veronica Brebner
captured both the look of the commoner
and the Queen as they painstakingly
applied their craft and ingenuity to
reflect the period authentically and the
Oscar goes to the Oscar goes to Jenny
sure kawar for Elizabeth
this is the first Oscar for Jenny shirk
or whose credits include the secret
garden and Mary Riley
thank you very much I'm overjoyed and
Kate this is because of you really Kate
looks so wonderful as our Queen
Elizabeth and the way she wore the hair
and makeup that we applied for her you
did this and also thank you to my whole
team that worked with me my Sarah
Phillips of facial hair maker and Terry
Jarvis my brilliant wig maker and
everybody else Mary Richards to give me
the money to do it with and Kate for
Kate luncheon thank you very much